[Music]
hi everyone
today i'm really excited to talk about
moore's law
which roughly states that every two
years computational power doubles
and this is such an important concept
that underpins all of our modern
technological progress
the digital age the age of computers is
driven by moore's law
and a lot of the progress that we've
seen in my lifetime uh
and and longer in the last 50 uh 55
years has been driven
by this idea that if you wait a little
while
computers will be faster and you can
solve harder problems
okay so i love this uh this comparison
of tomb raider circa 1996 the original
tomb raider
and uh the new tomb raider from a couple
of years ago 2018
and this is just staggering kind of the
difference
in rendering capabilities this is real
time footage of the game being
being played and you can see that in in
24 years
there have been remarkable advances in
what's possible in real time
uh for video games same thing in uh
computer graphics uh for for movies so
if you look at at a
cgi you know 20 years ago to now it's
it's really quite breathtaking
but moore's law is not only useful for
for video games and movies
it also allows us to solve bigger and
bigger
computational problems for science and
for engineering
which have huge impacts in society so
this is
a great video by the kth team in sweden
of a
simulation of a turbulent boundary layer
so this is like the flow over a wing or
over a truck
at absolutely exquisite detail and
in full resolution so 10 20 years ago
this wouldn't have been possible
and now with supercomputers you can get
this breathtaking look
into very complex turbulent flows
and again in another 10 20 30 years this
might be something that you can solve
on your cell phone okay so really uh
quite
quite exciting you can also use this to
simulate
protein folding and molecular dynamics
so this is very topical this is a
simulation of
a piece of the covid19 virus
that was simulated using this folding
at-home
kind of crowd-sourced computation but
again
these these big computer simulations of
important problems in science and
engineering
are possible now because of moore's law
of exponential growth and computer power
and it's allowing us to solve these
problems closer and closer to real time
so that we can design new drugs so that
we can design
better engineering systems okay so
uh moore's law essentially says that you
know
in time computers get bigger and faster
um so this is the cray one from 1976.
this is the mira blue jean computer in
2013 just massively more powerful
there's a fun corollary to moore's law
which is that computers don't just get
bigger and faster they're also getting
smaller and more portable
so we are all carrying around a super
computer in our pockets now
and that's pretty remarkable okay so in
this
video i'm going to walk you through kind
of what moore's law is
why it exists in the first place who was
more
and we're also going to talk about why
this is important what are the
implications for the future
and do we expect moore's law to continue
forever
and how is it how is it going to end
okay so i'm steve brunton
i'm really excited to walk you through
this i do want to point out
if you find this useful or interesting
please like and subscribe
write comments about other videos you'd
like me to do
and you can also find me on twitter at
eigensteve
all right so what is moore's law
and who was more so this is gordon moore
and his uh his partner noyce
they co-founded intel which
was a company that made uh made made
microchips
out of transistors okay and more gordon
moore wrote this wonderful paper
called cramming more components onto
integrated circuits
in 1965 and what he was essentially
doing was
forecasting what would computers look
like 10 years later in 1975
okay so now computers are are this
powerful
how powerful are they going to be in the
future and that's a pretty bold
uh bold thing to do making a forecast
uh 10 years in the future about an
entire new field is a very gutsy move
and that's one of the reasons why this
is such a famous paper
and why why moore's law is such an
important idea okay
so the idea is that computers so your
your personal computer your laptop
computer your cell phone
have chips inside and those chips the
logic of what your computer is doing in
computing
is being performed with transistors
these little kind of logical
units that build up more and more
complex computers
and so you have in your computer a ton
of
transistors back in 1960
moore was essentially basing
his projection on this data so this was
the the number of transistors
from you know just before 1960 to 1965
and what moore said was that computers
are going to keep
the number of transistors is going to
double every year
for the foreseeable future okay so he
this is when moore's law was defined
with this little amount of data and this
is how moore's law has actually
progressed
uh over over the last decades okay and
so i think this is pretty
remarkable is with this small amount of
information
moore made this observation that
computer power
was not going to grow linearly it was
not going to grow
any other way except for this
exponential growth this is in a log
coordinates so you can see that every
every certain amount of time the
computer power is doubling
now originally he said the computer
power would double every one year
uh in 1975 he revised that to every two
years
so you got to give him you know that
fudge right there that fudge factor that
you know he he had to recalibrate this
the slope of this line
so that he said that moore's law grows
uh computers double
every two years okay still an extremely
remarkable prediction
uh the name moore's law was coined by
carver mead at caltech
um and i think it's kind of funny that
you know gordon moore's name is a big
part of the reason why
uh i think this is so catchy if it was
gordon les les's law just doesn't
doesn't have the same ring to it when
the whole point is that if you wait
longer you get more okay
so that's that's one statement of
moore's law and it has been
true for a long long time actually even
if you go
way back uh to kind of the mechanical
era of computations
um so some of these are pretty
interesting so analytic
engines uh tabulators the ibm tabulator
the colossus the eniac
and so on and so forth there is this
kind of growth of complexity of
computation
that has roughly speaking followed this
exponential trend for a long time
and that's pretty cool something else
i'd like to point out there's other ways
that you could phrase moore's law
there's a lot of ways of saying this you
could say that every two years
computer power doubles that's kind of
the most general way that i like to
think about it
the specific language of the original
moore's law was that
every so often the transistor
density is going to double so you're
going to pack more transistors in the
same
surface area of a chip that's another
way to say it
you could also say that one one
formulation of moore's law
is that every two years the cost of the
a given amount of computer power is cut
in half
so the cost of computing goes uh
goes down for at a given amount of
computing power
the cost gets cut in half every two
years and these are all
very valid uh statements of moore's law
um
that i think you should be aware of okay
good
so i want to talk about exponential
growth just a little bit i have a whole
other
kind of long video on what exponential
growth is
why it exists why it's called
exponential growth
and why eventually exponential growth
you know has to saturate
and curtail but here we're going to look
at
the number of transistors over time
following moore's law
okay so if you start with kind of this
could be one transistor this could be
1000 transistor whatever
but if you start with one then what this
says is that after two years
the number of transistors doubles after
four years it quadruples
after six years it's eight times more
powerful
than 16 times more powerful and so on
and so forth you have to zoom out
because these numbers are going to get
really big really fast
and every two years this doubles and
doubles and keeps doubling
and that's quite amazing that means that
all you have to do is wait
and your computer is much much much more
powerful so in 20 years it's a thousand
times more powerful
than you started with okay now
you can uh model this using this
equation uh the kind of number of
transistors
at year k plus one is r times the number
of transistors
the previous year in this case r would
be the square root of 2 so that after
2 years this number doubles
and again it's often when you look at
exponential growth
it's useful to plot these on a log scale
so instead of on kind of
real linear units here we're going to
plot the number of transistors on a log
scale
so the number the spacing just gets
bigger and bigger and bigger at every
tick
i go up in the y direction and so now
you can see that moore's law
looks linear when plotted in these
logarithmic coordinates and that's how
people usually plot this
because it allows you to see what's
happening a lot more clearly
okay good and so uh
einstein actually thought that
exponential growth was super cool
um he says compound interest is the
eighth wonder of the world this is one
of my favorite quotes
he who understands it earns it he who
doesn't pays it
okay so basically what he's saying is
that if you invest your money
and you reinvest your interest you're
going to earn and if you don't you're
going to be paying
but compound interest is what's behind
this idea of exponential growth
and moore's law and i think there's this
great quote
by by sir arthur conan doyle the more we
progress
the more we tend to progress and this
really is
the statement of moore's laws the faster
our computers get
the more faster they get and so kind of
this is true
of all technology and all of science in
human histories the more knowledge we
have
the faster knowledge grows and that's
also
what's happening in uh in semiconductors
okay good so exponential growth is also
you know everywhere it's not just
moore's law in semiconductors this also
describes the spread of diseases it
describes the u.s
gross domestic product over time so this
is about 100 years
of the u.s gdp and you can see that it's
very
exponential even given you know the
great depression
recession stock market crashes all of
that
when you plot this on again on these log
coordinates you get a nice clean line
and that's another argument behind why
moore's law might be true
is because essentially semiconductors
and and computers have become central to
the world economy right this is
they have become ubiquitous in the world
economy it's part of why the economy
works the way it does is because of
computers
and because they are have tapped into
the economy and become a natural part of
this exponential growth
computers themselves are growing faster
and faster there is an economic
incentive to build a computer that's
twice as fast
because we will be twice as productive
so we're
pouring money into research and into
development and into technology to make
faster chips
and to get more transistors on those
chips so that's you know kind of one
argument is because chips
and and semiconductors have become so
important for the world economy
that is why we're investing in making
them faster and faster and faster
okay good um and this is a nice diagram
i like
from wikipedia which basically just
shows all of the
various chips and how they've very very
closely followed moore's law
over time more and more and more
transistors
in these in these chips pretty
impressive okay
so at this point i want to just zoom out
and remind you why this matters okay so
yeah computers are getting faster um
and of course this allows us to
do digital communication so for example
you're watching this video on youtube
it was massively compressed by youtube's
algorithm and it is being decompressed
in real
time so that they can send it to you
over the internet
and you're watching this either on your
computer or on your phone
or whatever but whatever device you're
watching this on is doing this
incredibly sophisticated decompression
in real time so that you can watch this
okay so all of our digital
communications
you know netflix youtube all of it is
really relying on
fast fast fast computers that you can
fit in the palm of your hand
okay from my perspective as a as an
engineer
and as a scientist is that we want to
solve
bigger and bigger technological problems
so i showed you that protein folding
and that fluid simulation we want to be
able to solve
more and more sophisticated problems and
we want to be able to solve them faster
so in that fluids example i want to be
able to solve the full fluid flow over
a wing of an airplane in real time
because then i might be able to develop
a control strategy
to increase the lift and decrease the
drag now at this point we are
decades maybe maybe more than 100 years
away from being able to solve that level
of fluids problem in real time
but the hope is with moore's law if you
wait
you know two years four years eight
years if you wait longer and longer
computer power will grow at such a
tremendous rate that we do have some
hope
of solving these these really large
really important problems
again that will have a tremendous
economic and societal impact and that's
why
we're going to try hard to build those
computers okay
this is also quite topical now you know
artificial intelligence and machine
learning is growing at an incredible
rate
because computers have finally become
powerful enough
uh that they can they can learn these
incredible rules
uh to play games to beat humans at go
uh to learn you know how to drive a car
without a human right there's incredible
advances in machine learning and there's
more
advances to be had because computer
power is allowing us
to solve these increasingly
sophisticated problems okay so moore's
law
is super relevant for us in a daily in
our daily lives
you know for for digital communication
for streaming tv
it's also important for society and for
industry and for technology to develop
new technologies
and it's having profound impacts uh in
areas like
scientific computing and machine
learning
and so i think there's some pretty
interesting forward-looking
ideas about moore's law that i want to
walk you through okay so this is kind of
a neat diagram of
moore's law over time from from
wikipedia
from electromechanical to relay
computers to vacuum tubes transistors
integrated circuits and so on okay and
you get this nice
log linear now if you kind of zoom out
and extrapolate into the future so what
might the future hold
then you get some pretty interesting uh
thought experiments
so if moore's law keeps going and going
and going for another 10
20 30 40 years for another 100 years at
what point do our computers become
as smart as powerful as our brains as
powerful as an insect brain
as powerful as a mouse brain as powerful
as a human brain
and at what point do they become as
powerful as all human brains
so this is kind of an interesting
thought experiment if moore's law
keeps keeps progressing if computers
keep doubling
in their capacity and their power at
some point
computers might you know machine
learning and computers
might be as powerful as humans or more
powerful
and so this is what kurzweil calls the
law of accelerating returns this is very
similar to what
sir arthur conan doyle said about the
more knowledge we have the faster that
knowledge grows
and you know at some point this
extrapolation
will will lead to uh possibly computers
being
being more powerful than humans and this
is called the singularity where
computers kind of become sentient or
self-aware or smarter than humans i mean
there's a lot of different definitions
of the singularity but it has a lot of
very
smart people thinking about you know the
natural progression of where computing
is going
now you know there's cool uh flashy time
articles and a lot of press on this idea
you probably have heard this before the
singularity
i know elon musk talks about this lots
of people talk about this
it's really interesting to think about
now i'm a little
skeptical i'm a little pessimistic
because i know
and you should know too that exponential
growth doesn't go on forever it never
can it never has and it never will at
some point
there will be some process that keeps us
from going exponentially
okay and i think that's really important
for for us all to keep in mind
and we don't know when that'll happen
maybe that'll happen in five years maybe
that'll happen in 50 years maybe it'll
happen in 500 years
and and those all will have big uh that
makes a big difference when
this exponential growth ends okay
there's a diagram i really like from
this science paper
which instead of just plotting you know
transistor density
in time what they're plotting here is
power density
kind of how much power you can fit in a
small area
versus clock frequency how fast your
computer is clocking
and you can also see that over time
computers have
kind of progressed from lower left to
the upper right
and you're just getting more and more
and more kind of
higher frequency and also higher power
density
but it's interesting the human brain
lives way down here
very low clock frequency it's not ultra
ultra fast cycles
and it's also very low power density
your brain
is not at risk of super heating and
doesn't need a massive heat sink
you do of course have thermal regulation
systems but the brain lives down here
so our goal of trying to get denser and
faster might not be the way
that we reach you know artificial
intelligence and computers that think
like humans
okay i think that's really important for
us to to remember is that there's
something
pretty special going on in uh in
biological brains
that we are really not capturing in
mechanical
brains and computers okay and i also
want to point out just this
absurdity of extrapolation okay so
extrapolating computer growth a hundred
years in the future
is kind of an absurd uh idea
okay so this is one of my favorite
diagrams this is from the economist and
it's called blade running and it's the
number of
blades per razor system over time okay
so
the last hundred years has seen
tremendous advances in razor blade
technology
from a single razor on your razor blade
to two razors
to three the mach 3 to the quattro
right so razors have gotten much much
better in the last hundred years
but if you fit an exponential to this
and you project forward
into the future you get absurd
conclusions that by the year 2100 you
will have trillions
maybe of blades on your razor blade and
that doesn't seem
very reasonable okay so extrapolation is
dangerous
another paper i just absolutely love
this
not not this nature paper but the the
rebuttal to this
so there was this idea i don't know if
you can see this but this is kind of
um how long men
and women run a certain race over time
so these are like the fastest
world record running times uh for men
and for women
per year and essentially what they
showed
was that um
the prediction in this nature paper was
that it's a little hard to read this but
in you know
over a hundred years in a couple hundred
years women will be running
this race faster than men okay right now
the fastest woman is slower than the
fastest man but women's
speeds are going down oh
sorry i completely botched this it's
a tiny screen so sorry women's
running time are higher than men's they
take longer to run than the men's
but their times are decreasing faster
okay so women's times are getting
faster faster than men's times are and
so the projection is that at some point
in the future
women will be running this race faster
than men will okay that may very well be
true
but there were essentially comments
in the rebuttal to this nature paper
that said that if you project even
farther into the future 2600 the year
2600
the really remarkable fact is that both
men and women will be running this race
in negative time in less than zero
seconds
okay so that's this kind of sprint
research um
they omit to mention however that
according to their analysis
a far more interesting race should occur
in about 26 36
when times of less than zero seconds
will be reached i'd love this
uh this rebuttal but it points out the
absurdity
of extrapolating models too far into the
future okay yes this data looks
relatively linear right now
but at some point presumably this trend
will have to
to end okay uh and of course you know we
can model this
uh using our original growth equation
if there can be these saturation
mechanisms which eventually
you know cause your exponential growth
which follows exponential growth for a
long time
to eventually start to taper out and
saturate now again we don't know when
this is going to happen
but it will eventually have to happen
right like computer chips
are made of silicon and right now we are
getting to the
atomic limit of how how few uh silicon
atoms we can actually make these
transistors out of
okay and so there have been a lot of
predictions for a long time for for most
of my life people have been predicting
when is moore's law is going to
going to end it's going to end in 10
years is it going to end in 20 years
moore himself has proposed that moore's
law will end at some point and then he
revised that to 2025
about five years ago so it's really a
question of when
not not if okay
and it's already starting to happen in
some sense so if you look at
kind of the single thread performance
it is starting to taper off okay that
that's
certainly true but if you look at
parallel processing so the rise of of
gpus or graphics processing units
instead of having a single core that has
really really dense transistor
packing now we're starting to have
hundreds maybe thousands of these cores
on these graphics processing units and
so that's still giving us this
incredible
kind of moore's law continued trend of
computing because
even though individual processors are
tapering off in their performance
we're starting to get more and more
processors on the same chip
okay and i think this is a really nice
diagram
um this is from a different more that
basically shows
you know even though the single thread
performance is tapering off
the total transistor count is still
going up
and the number of cores the number of
kind of individual
processors on these big you know
graphics processor units
is still increasing uh quite rapidly so
you know this is definitely still
continuing
the trend uh of moore's law
now i want to point out some future
technologies right there are some some
kind of
future ongoing projections of what's
going to happen in computers this is all
a lot of it's speculative we know right
now that gpus and cloud computing
is becoming a big deal so instead of
having one ultra ultra fast computer
processor
now we have thousands of processors in
these gpus
and we have thousands and thousands of
these gpus in these server farms in this
these cloud computing farms right so
google
has access to just rack after rack after
rack of gpu
which each one has hundreds or thousands
of little processors
so this massive massive parallelization
is an ongoing trend
um another one i think is super
interesting is variable precision
so lots of computer problems lots of the
the problems you're
you're going to be solving on your
computer they don't have to be solved to
the ultra
ultra high precision that your computer
processor is built to be working at
this is already being used in video
games when they realize you don't need
double precision information about how
to render a scene
single precision is fine people can't
tell the difference
and so variable precision figuring out
when you need more precision and when
you need
less can massively speed up and improve
computational algorithms
probabilistic computing is a huge area
that is currently being
developed so there are some algorithms
that don't scale well with moore's law
these are like
non-polynomial time algorithms that are
just
really really hard like knapsack problem
the traveling salesman problem
uh solving a game of chess these are all
really hard
sudoku actually is a is an np hard
problem
to solve to solve that game but we're
coming up with algorithms that don't
deterministically
solve a problem they probabilistically
solve a problem
and with very very high probability they
can reach a solution
that is nearly optimal but in a
in an algorithm that scales very
favorably uh
with with moore's law so that's super
exciting we're also getting into the era
of quantum computing
so instead of solving a problem you know
using these kind of deterministic steps
like a traditional computer does quantum
computing
may allow us to solve very very very
hard kind of np-hard problems
um you know in in one shot
photonic computing is a really big one
so again transistors are based on
kind of electrons moving through wires
in your computer
and that causes things to heat up and
there's resistance
and there's limits on how small and how
fast you can make these things
before they get hot photonic computing
doesn't suffer from a lot of those
problems and so there's a lot of
research going into
computing with light instead of with
electrons
there's also really interesting advances
in neuromorphic computing so trying to
do things more like how
how biology does them so for example
your retina
um the you know the cells in your retina
don't
aren't aren't acting like a ccd in a
camera they're not acting like a
microchip
they are collecting information and when
they get enough information
they fire okay and they only fire when
they need to fire
so can we make computers that only
communicate and only
process when they need to when they have
enough information that they're needed
that's a really interesting idea all of
these
are going to change how we perceive
moore's law in the next 10
20 30 40 years okay and so we've talked
about moore's law
how you have this kind of exponential
growth of computer power
we've talked about this corollary of
moore's law that computers aren't just
getting bigger and faster they're
getting
uh smaller more portable you know they
have sensor systems on board
we all have them in our pockets there's
something i want to point out
is that we still have a lot to learn
from biology
so you know the insect brain
is pretty powerful and you know it's not
growing exponentially over time
yet the insect is able to handle very
very complex uh
simulation and control kind of problems
right it's flying through
very complex flow fields and it's doing
just the right thing
to live its life it's it's really quite
amazing what biology can do
with relatively limited resources
and so just relying on moore's law and
brute force and bigger
stronger more powerful computers is not
always
the way to go sometimes we want to
finesse the solution sometimes we want
to learn how to do things
with less and i think that's that's a
pretty important
important takeaway so
i love moore's law i think it's just
amazing to watch the progress
of computation in my lifetime i'm
looking forward to you know what my
kids see in their lifetime with this
progressing computer power with what
it's enabling
in scientific computing in in machine
learning
and i think there's pretty important
implications for just kind of society
in general so i want you to be thinking
about exponential growth i want you to
be thinking about kind of the past
uh decades of computer and what the
future might hold
all right thank you